the first images of a rush hour tragedy
they show mangled subway cars packed
with commuters this crash left many dead
and dozens of people injured in its
aftermath rescuers race to free those
still trapped it's terrible of course I
don't want to ride the Metro anymore and
I'm sorry for those people to choose
there's no so blue dead but I don't need
to look at how transport plans and
regulations are working I'm a technician
I think someone didn't pay attention to
other things were working with no June
imatinib so provided for hours rescuers
struggle to save victims of the incident
passengers were ferried by helicopters
to the city's hospitals at the scene
many survivors were battered and bruised
emergency workers offered first aid to
the injured and covered up those who
could no longer be helped right now
investigators believe a power surge
caused the accident they are theory the
Train stalled and three cars derailed
but their probe into what happened
continues us mortal what we're looking
at everything talking to survivors and
investigating the site our probe at the
scene isn't yet over we're putting all
the means and manpower at our disposal
into this Moscow's Metro is one of the
largest subway systems in the world it
transports nearly 10 million passengers
every day this incident may shake
confidence in the famed subway